under the joint supervision of professor
peter pico and
myself and right now rachel is a faculty
member in the school of mathematics and
statistics at the university of sydney
so today her talk is about global
community detection thanks richard
thank you hi em for the very nice
introduction um
and thank you everyone for you know
coming to the first talk in the moment
in the morning
yeah so it's my great pleasure to be
able to give a talk at this workshop
which is also celebrating peter's
belated 80th birthday
so i'm going to talk about some recent
work with my collaborators
xiaohan from university of science and
technology china
and xintong from usc
um so
on partial information networks so
statistical networks is an area um which
peter and many of you here have made a
lot of fundamental contributions to
yeah so peter and many of you here have
made a lot of fundamental contributions
to the area of statistical networks and
i was very fortunate to be introduced to
this area when i was a phd student here
so
a network which doesn't need much
introduction for this audience it's just
a graph with nodes and edges
and we're talking about social networks
here so the set of nodes um represent a
set of individuals in in index from one
to n
and the edges represent some kind of
relationship friendship interactions
among them and in the simplest case
these are binary and undirected edges
so what are some of the statistical
problems we are interested in or we can
estimate um the latent community
memberships right and communities are
groups of people more tightly connected
with each other than with the rest of
the network
um and this will also be the focus of
our work so these communities can be you
know people graduated from the same high
school people sharing a common interest
and so on
we can also estimate
the number of subgraph counts so we can
count the triangles wheels stars in the
network and they tell us something about
the connectivity patterns in the network
we can also do inference on node
covariates so they tell us something
about the personal traits in this case
um so most of the current work assumes
you either have a global view so you
have access to the whole network or you
have some edges missing at random in the
network
or you can sample multiple subgraphs
from the whole network and then combine
information from them to infer
say global community structure and peter
puna and shimando recently had a very
interesting paper on this approach
patching together information from
multiple subgraphs
but the question is so as an individual
in the network
i often need to make decisions based on
my local view of the network alone right
so for example i need to decide whether
i want to share a piece of information
with someone else and the the decision
is based on which friend circle social
circle that person belongs to
and at the same time i don't have the
full network fee
so the question is as an individual in
the network how much of the full network
do i get to see
so
in the first layer i know who are my
friends right these are the people
directly connected to me so i see these
edges
uh and i probably also know who are my
friends friends
um and
for most of us
that's probably the extent of our social
knowledge that's for for me this is
going to be the extent of my social
knowledge any edges further away from me
um i'm not going to see them
so it is
[Music]
definitely possible that we can some
people can see further away from the
center
but the key point is if i take an
individual as the center
whether another edge in the network is
observed by that person or not depends
on the distance from the center in other
words
the path length
if i start walking from the center
and this is what motivated us to think
about the setup and which we call it
individual centered partial information
network
and here is just the toy example
illustrating making the idea more
concrete so we have six individuals and
this toy network connecting these six
people
on the left most panel
and now let's say we take individual one
as the center and we will use l this
capital letter l to denote what we call
uh knowledge depth which which is
essentially just path lengths from the
center so when l is equal to one um this
person just see a star around them when
l is equal to two um
they they get to see almost the full
network on the left except for this edge
between five and six
and i don't see this edge because this
edge lies on the path of lens three
starting from the center
and when l is equal to three
i recover the full network
so the idea is that we're going to
characterize the amount of partial
information or local information
perceived by individual one
using path lengths and we call it
knowledge steps and this is denoted
capital letter l here
so
um
for this we're going to focus on the
value um l equals 2 in this case because
um as we know in the you know as long as
the network is not too sparse even the
moderately large l is going to return
almost the full network
so that's not very interesting and l
equals equal to 1 is not very
interesting either it's just a star
um so maybe
l equals 2 or l equals equals 3 will be
the most interesting cases and we're
going to focus on l equals 2 and leave
of course 3 for future work
okay so the question again is that we
want to infer global community
membership just using this partial
information for l equals two
so of course the structure of our
partial network is related to
many popular network sampling schemes in
quantitative social science so including
egocentric sampling snowball sampling
um respondent driven sampling rds
and so on so in and all these sampling
methods work by first choosing some seed
nodes
and then ask them to recruit their
neighbors in some sense right so in ego
sampling english centric sampling you
take the center and then recruit the
neighbors and look at the connections
between the neighbors and snowball
sampling and rds do this in waves right
so you first ask them to recruit their
neighbors and then ask the neighbors to
recruit their neighbors and this waves
of sampling continues until you have
reached a desired sample size and rds
you can also do probabilistic sampling
and you have a
weighted average of those samples um and
the main difference between our
conceptual framework and this one is
that we are interested in um what one
instance of the partial network can
offer
and at the end of the day we are
interested in comparing
what network structure is visible to
each individual
and most of the rds methods are based on
are focused on
estimating node covariance but we are
interested in latent community structure
and in some special cases you may not
get to sample
multiple subgraphs from a restricted
network
so coming back to the setup we have this
graph with nodes and edges and as usual
we'll use the adjacency matrix to
represent this
symmetric undirected network with an
edge so so a i j is equal to 1 if
there's an edge connecting nodes i and j
now we are going to use the matrix b
um to to denote
individual ones perceived
adjacency matrix based on l equals two
and without loss of generality we are
always going to assume we are going to
we are centering at individual one
because if you are interested in any
other individual we just permit matrix
okay so back to this toy example um here
is my matrix a the full adjacency matrix
and this is my matrix b corresponding to
this middle paddle here so the only
difference is between individual 5 and 6
this edge i don't observe in b
in general we can represent the
relationship between a and b like this
um an edge between i and j
is observed by this individual one right
it shows up in matrix b if and only if
um at least one of the ij nodes is a
neighbor of individual one so here this
edge is not absorbed because neither
five or six is a neighbor of one
more succinctly we can represent this
relationship using a matrix relationship
um this so b is connected to a through
this s matrix s matrix is a diagonal
matrix where the entries represent uh
they encode whether an individual is a
neighbor of individual one
so before i dig into the theoretical
appeal
oh yes yes
it's a bit cliche yes so um before i dig
into uh the theoretical analysis i want
to sort of present a teaser kind of
result on this zachary karate club which
we all know and maybe we are too
familiar with but the point is
even with this very
well analyzed the world study network
using our method and framework we can
still get some interesting observations
so here's the network itself
if you haven't seen this before this is
the social network relationship between
among members of a karate club and then
there's two hubs
in the network there's the node h
h and the node a so one of them is the
instructor and the other is an
administrator and the network's split
into two communities after dispute
between these two people
this is the network itself with two
communities
and here i have selected some
individuals including the two hubs
and
i take their own partial information
network
i take each one of these individuals at
the center and look at the partial
information network and try to do
community global global community
detection and this is the accuracy i get
in the end and i will talk about the
algorithm later
and the first first row shows the degree
how many people they are connected to
and this is the fraction of edges they
observe in the full network so we can
see that these two nodes um the two hubs
in fact don't have the best performance
um they don't perform as well as say
individual 20 and in individual 32 who
both have fewer edges than the two hubs
and especially individual 20
only 3 degrees and 50 of the edges and
they almost have a perfect answer so a
closer look at this connection we see
that 20
uh is
so out of the three degrees two of them
are connected to the hubs
right so this is sort of saying that you
don't need to be the most important
person in the network you just have to
be connected to uh
important people in each community and
we will try to um illustrate we try to
capture this message without theoretical
analysis later under the block model
setup
um so
the general analysis we did it under a
generic low rank assumption we assumed
the population matrix has rank k
and then it has this usual eigenvalue
eigen decomposition and d is the matrix
of diagonal matrix of different
eigenvalues and v is the corresponding
eigenvector matrix
so d and v are population quantities
and then a is generated independent
bernoulli from the population
so we all know that the usual
theoretical analysis proceeds by
decomposing a into the signal plus noise
and the signal is the population version
and the noise is the fluctuation
so we don't get to see a we get to see
this partial adjacency matrix b instead
so the question is what is the signal
term here um
for for b
so it turns out the signal term here
which we denote by b sub e
has this particular form so it is not
the expected value of this whole thing
it is not the expected value of the
individual terms in fact expectation is
only applied to a and s is left as a
random quantity outside so this signal
term is a random term
and the reason is um there's a s square
term here uh and s is the diagonal
matrix of bernoulli random variables so
if you square bernoulli you still get a
boundary but that's much bigger than a
square of the expectation the p p square
which go which gets small when p goes to
zero
and it's the signal term of the b matrix
in this sense if i look at the spectral
norm of the difference it's
smaller than or equal to the smallest
singular value of v e
so next i'm going to talk a little bit
about the theoretical properties of be
which allows us to do
spectral clustering later
so if i assume these two matrices are
invertible
then i can show the rank of be is
exactly 2k
and furthermore if i index the
eigenvalue eigenvector pair from
negative k to -1 and then 1 to k then
this eigenvalue eigenvector pair has the
following form
so
x i so i need to first construct a
matrix here h
so h
so x here is a scalar quantity
and h depends on the population
quantities d and v these are coming from
the eigen eigen decomposition of the
population matrix as well as the s
matrix
so after i have constructed this h
matrix i look at the determinant
equation and set it to zero and find all
the solutions to this determinant
equation and it turns out the inverse is
one of my eigenvalues of the b e matrix
and for the eigenvector the eigenvector
has two parts the sum of two parts so i
construct the first part q1
by substituting in the
corresponding eigenvalue
and
find
an eigenvector corresponding to the zero
eigenvalue here
that's the first part and the second
part
is linked to the first part by this
equation here and then i connect the two
by multiplying the s and the i minus s
so intuitively s
is
s picks out the uh neighbors the
the rows corresponding to the neighbors
of individual one i minus one picks out
the non-neighbors in the rows
corresponding to individual ones
so i put all these q's together and call
this the big q matrix and the bigq
matrix
consists of two parts the neighboring
part and the non-neighboring part
and i can further orthogonalize this
system so
i get this uh so q q can be
the little q can be chosen such that the
big q becomes also normal matrix
um
so we can derive further properties on
the eigenvalues of the signal term be so
let p and be the maximum probability
connection probability and here just
just saying uh the neighbors of
individual one that edge density behaves
like p n and then i have the usual log n
lower bound on p n
um then this is uh
we can get more details on the
eigenvalues in the following sense so
first of all the orders of these
eigenvalues behaves like this
and if i let p and go to zero and with
some additional constraint of
eigenvalues we can
obtain a high probability expressions of
these eigenvalues so exactly k of these
eigenvalues are positive and like the
other k of them are negative
so for the purpose of spectral
clustering later i don't need to know
the
these high probability forms of
eigenvalue i just need to know the order
however a closer look at these high
probability expressions
gives us some interesting observations
so it turns out if i
call this lambda mean this is the
the smallest eigenvalue of this matrix
here vt sv
it determines the gap between the
smallest eigenvalue
in magnitude so singular value and zero
and we know that this gap influences how
well you can do a spectral clustering
later
so um
lander main drives the signal behind
the spectral cluster
so just a quick summary of the
theoretical properties i have shown so
far so first we derived this eigenvector
matrix q
and it consists of two parts the
neighbors of node one and the
non-neighbors of node one and we derive
the order of the eigenvalues
and we have this quantity this eigen gap
here lambda mean
determines the signal strength of
spectral clustering
later and since lambda main influences
the performance of spectral clustering
we can think of it as a centrality
measure for individual one and it's a
centrality measure in the sense that it
assesses uh individual ones awareness of
the global structure so it tells us how
tells us how important individual one is
you know determining
the overall global community structure
so we are proposing this as a new
centrality measure
it turns out the landaming naturally
lies between zero and one
and even though we don't know v this is
the population quantity the population
eigenvectors
we can estimate this using the empirical
version of a so we have an empirical
version of blender mean
and we can show that when k is equal to
one and lambda main
bears connections to the degree
centrality and eigenvector centrality so
it's in fact a combination of both
pieces of information
big k is the low rank assumption is the
rank of the population expected value of
a
yes oh sorry
okay okay next one question
okay so now we're going to do some uh
concrete calculations of missed
clustering rate on the
usual block model setup so we first
consider the
simple stochastic block model where the
population
version can be written in this form
where so p is the k by k connectivity
matrix and pi is the binary
membership matrix
n by k binary membership matrix
and then the connection between node i
and j the probability of connection is
entirely determined by their membership
so i don't get to see a
i get to see b
and uh we can show that in fact in the q
matrix which is the eigenvectors of the
be the signal term of the matrix b there
are exactly two types of rows
in q
um even though we don't catch cq and
this is the usual business with spectral
clustering um we get to see an empirical
version of b
or got to see an empirical version of b
which is b so we can um
cluster uh the w the empirical version
of q instead provided you know p uh the
q and and w are close enough and there's
enough um signals between the different
types of q to separate the nodes
and this is um what we are trying to
capture with this level with this lemma
here so pn is again the maximum
connection probability and here i'm just
saying uh so here i'm assuming without
loss of generality individual one always
belongs to
community one
then this p and again is the edge
density around the individual one and
then some usual assumptions on the size
of each community and the minimum
singular value of the k by k
connectivity matrix and here's the lower
bound on the edge density
then
we can show there are two two k types of
rows in
in this uh in this matrix q and there
are three cases
when
node i and j don't belong to the same
community then their corresponding rows
in q are different and they're lower
about the difference is lower bounded by
this
if i and j belong to the same community
but exactly one of them is a neighbor of
individual one then the corresponding
rows in q are different again and
they're lower bounded by this
only if they belong to the same
community and um that either they are
both neighbors of individual one or they
are both non-neighbors of individual one
then these rows will agree so there are
exactly
two k types of rows in here and k types
of rows in the neighbors and k types of
rows in the non-neighbors
yeah so this is coming from the fact
that we only have access to b which is
not the full a and so you lose a lot of
edges in the matrix b and you can
actually see this from the order of the
eigenvalues here so usually this is n
times pn so we have another factor of pn
to the half here so that that's where
it's coming from so the signal here is
just a lot smaller compared to the full
so um
from that lemma now we have this
clustering algorithm we're going to
treat basically the neighbors of one and
the non-neighbors one separately and
apply some kind of cl clustering
algorithm to put these
two groups of individuals into k groups
so after we do k means on each group
then each clustering is going to return
us
a cluster with uh
so it's going to return us a group of k
clusters right so i have two k clusters
in total from the neighbors and from the
non-neighbors
so the next step is to merge them into k
communities and we know that this
clustering only gives us labels um
identifiable up to permutation so we
need a way of merging
and then the way we merge it is that we
construct two estimates of the k by k
connectivity matrix so the first
estimate is constructed by uh looking at
neighbors of individual one and i i do a
sort of frequency count and and then the
estimated this p
and this one is estimated by looking at
so one of them is a neighbor and the
other one is normally but the
rectangular part and i get another
estimate of the p and then i try to
match the the two by looking by
minimizing the frobenius norm and find
the most optimal permutation to merge
the two groups
so using this algorithm we can show that
uh
if my pn is lower bounded by this then i
achieve a weak consistency
and this is the upper bound on this
custom nodes now we notice that we lose
a bit more here because of the merging
step because when we construct uh these
two estimate the p here we need some
concentration properties and that's
that's the reason for this even higher
lower bound
so we can extend all of this to a degree
corrected block model
and
so the corrected block model allows us
to describe some sort of
you know individual specific features
in particular it's a degree
heterogeneity
so here we're using the theta matrix
it's a diagonal matrix
where theta i is the degree parameter
associated with individual i uh and the
population version looks like this
and when you
look at the connectivity between i and j
you just get these extra theta i and c j
at the front and for
easy for for ease of analysis we're
going to assume the theta i
uh are id random variables generated
from a certain distribution and the mean
of the distribution behaves like a
constant
so it turns out we can have a very
similar
clustering algorithm for the degree
corrected version
so here again i divided the nodes into
the neighbors and non-neighbors and to
account for degree heterogeneity we use
the standard approach in gene and
alexandria's paper which is to divide
out to normalize the rows by the
to normalize each row and then
find the centroid that minimizes this
2-1 norm
and again we have a merging step but
this time we need to account for the
degree parameters as well
and it turns out we can also have a
similar consistency weak reconsistency
result for the degree corrected case
so we notice that
in all of the above cases our upper
bound on the misclustered node doesn't
depend on its uniform for everyone right
and this is because we did everything in
the exchangeable setup so we can't
really tell the difference between how
everyone can do in terms of global
network detection
so we considered a conditional setting
so that our clustering error bounds can
reflect the neighborhood feature of
individual one
and also we introduce another um setup
which is that the degree the degree
parameters are generated from a two
component mixture model in the following
sense so there's f1 and f2 and the meat
mu2 is the mean of f2 and mu1 is the
mean of f1 so mu2 represents the degree
parameters for the hub nodes and mu1 is
the degree parameters for the non-hub
node so there's two types of nodes in my
network
and then i just need one more notation
so njk
is is is counting the number of
individuals who are neighbors connected
to individual one and uh you know j
denotes whether they're from they're a
hub node or non-hub node and uh they
belong to community k
little k
um and then i have this bound on the
miss cluster nodes so
uh and the
the key the key term is here so looking
at this term um this tells me that first
of all if i'm connected to more people
then this denominator is going to
going to be smaller so the degree does
help
but
um
at the same time if if i fix my degree
um if this n2k here which is the number
of hub nodes in in community k if i know
more powerful neighborhood neighbors
across all communities then this
denominator is also going to be smaller
so that's another piece of information
helping you to do uh community detection
and that's reflected in our karate club
example
and it turns out if you recall this
lambda min which we're proposing as a
centrality measure for individuals it
also it also behaves like this term
divided by n so the same
interpretation applies to the this
centrality measure
so now let me get to some simple
simulation result um
yeah
yeah
so do you um recover the rate of the
mobile phone section then if you have a
very powerful node from knows everyone
oh yeah so so that's that's why we need
to have
the the pn is defined as the maximum
connectivity probability so the pn has
an upper bound and in fact in these
cases pn is going to zero so we don't
include
zero but relatively right you can have
potentially you can observe a network
yeah i think if if you happen to have uh
someone who who can just almost observe
all the edits in the agent then this
message should just work yeah although
that's not considered the outstanding
because this s and theta we conditional
these are high probability events and
they don't include the case that you've
mentioned yes
what if your note is such that the
matrix a is equal to your matrices
you can just apply the standard
clustering
um from from my system i see so
um
so so if b is equal to a then it's not
rank 2k anymore
the the population version is not um
where it just so happens
that
l equals
equals j so that's the random version of
the proportion
could i just run spectral clustering and
that b and i'll get the same answer
again
we need to try
we actually haven't tried this
particular algorithm called the full
matrix
uh yeah i don't think we have tried it
so so
yeah i mean for for our method to work
you need to have the neighbors i guess
that the neighbors will still have
random cases the
uh the wrong neighbors
yeah i need to i need to try it out yeah
yeah but yeah good question we didn't
consider that case because it's sort of
ruled out by uh
these high probability events that were
conditional
uh yeah so some simulation results um
i'm generating a two k equals two dc spm
uh and the the degree parameters are id
uniform and and
this is the horizontal axis shows
different values of n and the vertical
axis shows the missed clustering rate
and these are different values of q so
we can see that in most cases it would
converge
um so here
i'm looking at the performance of the
centrality measure
i'm just generating one copy of the dcs
vm and then looking at everyone's
clustering accuracy using their partial
information network
and the the centrality and then
computing a vector of centrality
measures and a vector of clustering
output accuracy and looking at the
pearson and the spearman
correlations between the two vectors
so i'm comparing with degree centrality
fraction of edges eigenvector centrality
between this centrality and these other
correlations so we can see that as
expected the lander ming hat the
empirical version has the highest
correlation
and i can also look at the correlations
between each pair of these centrality
measures sorry if you can't see these
numbers here very clearly but basically
the other four types of centrality
measures have correlations or very close
to one in this simple synthetic network
and we have a correlation of around 0.7
with with these which suggests suggests
that we seem to capture a different
model of information compared to these
other four types of centrality measures
so i'd like to quickly talk about one
different real data not karate club
again
this is a very famous data which looks
at the
diffusion of information about a
microfinance program in indian villages
and this the original data set analysis
was published in science
so they're looking at
40-something indian villages and how
information about microfinance diffuse
throughout the village and the uptake
rate of the program in the end in each
village
so the social network in each village we
have households as notes and each edge
is undirected in binary representing any
of the 12 relationships which they have
collected in the survey so there's
borrowing lending of money and material
and we have community labels
um so what happened was in each village
they have a few predefined leaders
serving as the injection points of
information so what happened was
they called these leaders and told them
about this program and asked the leaders
to go back and spread information
in the village and then they look at the
participation rate
in the end so we analyzed the 39
villages and these villages are distant
enough from each other so they can be
viewed as independent social networks
and the number of households varying
between this and the k uh
varies between this
so the first thing we looked at is
so even though these leaders were
predefined by by their study um using
their own criteria we wanted to ask the
question do leaders actually have a
better awareness of global structure
than non-leaders and so here i'm
plotting the clustering accuracy
of the main clustering accuracy of
leaders in each village so there's 39
points here and anything lying above the
diagonals is saying the leader average
leader does a better job on average than
non-leaders in the village and indeed it
seems like in most villages they do have
a better awareness of global structure
and here again i'm looking at
correlation measures
between clustering accuracy and
different centrality measures
using pearson correlations female
correlation and between leaders and
non-leaders so these are the four groups
here
i've added a centrality measure the
diffusion centrality which was proposed
in the original science paper as a
measure to
sort of
look at how information spreads how
efficiently the information can spread
in each each village
so you can see that our lander ming is
though has the most stable and
relatively
higher correlations than the other
overall higher correlations than the
other
centrality measures
and finally
i want to look at the correlation
between the centrality measure versus
the participation rate in the
microfinance program so again each point
here is a village and i'm
doing this regression of participation
rate on the london mean of the leaders
in each village
so the left one is our centrality
measure and the right one is diffusion
centrality measure which was proposed in
the original paper to capture such
information so we can see that even
though london was originally divided
designed for capturing information about
community detection it still seems to
capture some useful information about
the participation rate in in the program
so
just to sum up we have introduced an
individual centered uh partial
information framework um to study the
problem of community detection in social
networks we have derived the theoretical
properties of the main signal term
in the partial adjacency matrix and we
have shown some consistency results and
we have in addition proposed a
centrality measure based on eigengap
so we believe there's still a lot of
future work we can do under this setup
um in particular uh so so far
there's this implicit requirement for
consistency that we need to reach almost
everyone in the network in order to get
consistency overall but instead you know
in a sparse network we can consider what
happens
uh when when i'm only interested in the
membership that if the individuals
reached by the partial network so i
don't care uh those that i haven't seen
in the network so we can extend it to
mixed membership um l equals three uh
how to determine k uh and um you know
what happens if our knowledge of the
partial network deteriorate as we go
away from the center and we can think
about putting multiple individuals
partial information together
um
and so i would like to just thank my
collaborators again and also uh e ching
ching with whom we talked about the
microfinance data and of course peter
who has always been the beacon of light
in my academic life and every time i
talk to peter i always feel i still have
so much to learn from him and he also
gave us some very helpful feedback on
this work
and with the last one minute i would
just like to do a one little promotion
of our other recent work
which again peter has given us a lot of
feedback and suggestions and
perspectives
and the topic is quite relevant to this
to this workshop so we actually looked
at the
impact of core statistical theory and
methodology papers on other scientific
disciplines in the past two decades so
including the era of big data uh and our
paper is forthcoming in patents which is
the data science journal by the cell
press
and we have the cleaned up data
available in our code here so if you are
interested in taking a look and doing
some more further modeling of the data
so and finally happy birthday peter and
thank you for everything
thank you russo for the nice work so we
have
time for one question
i think terrific um
one comment is that i have to admit
the first application of this that
occurred to me
would be let's say for the national
security agency yeah terrorist yes
exactly yes
um
and um the second thing is that that
there's some work which is unpublished
of sharma about acharya
where he uses geodesics essentially
to to uh identify communities yes and
there might be some
relation there and if i may add a third
comment is you make l equals three a
stop well
that's true of course in any of the
uh
more or less dense regimes but if you go
down far enough right where you where
you where your or your sparsity is just
a little bit better than than uh than
log n let's say for example then
you can pursue higher values of that
right
yeah yeah i think that empirically i i
guess we look i need to look at bigger
networks but empirically for example the
facebook network when we do uh l equal
two or l equals three you almost already
have that but yeah definitely you're
right you can we can look at that at
least in the theoretical
so so talking about that
when i have square root of n
average degree after two step i have
sort of expansion proportional to n
so would you expect that if you have a
general error that the
misclassification becomes good once you
get n to the one over l
because you would sort of expect that if
the network is random enough
and you have n to the one over l a
little bit more then you should see
essentially the whole network or at
least a positive proportion and that
should sort of be the threshold where
you can do things or cannot do things
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we are actually
thinking about uh the threshold value
like that where we just we just have
some rough calculations at this point
about uh the uh you know sort of the
when when you when this becomes very
easy and when becomes um uh very hard
and we're also thinking about you know
sort of uh
maybe we're not interested in
discovering everyone's community
membership and uh maybe it's okay to if
that person doesn't belong to my
community maybe it's okay to get it
wrong um so yeah we're thinking about
extensions like that too yes thank you
for the comment
thanks ruto again